you do look pretty banger handsome here
tonight turn it down a night you know
I'm gonna do two loud colors but you
know it's all about other people tonight
not around me yeah
it's always about you bro okay sometimes
I mean it always ends up being about me
bruh I start out with it not being about
me okay so I we do got to go back to
Oscar night he gave me the field Sam
when Mike jumped in your arms and it was
one of the best things I've ever seen in
my life I was trying to pound him out lo
you know I actually got low and I was
trying to like bow bow and this thing I
know he will army clamming me like a
tree it was like oh oh that surgery stop
how much does he weighs because he looks
like he could be flipped amuck in that
moment the adrenaline the adrenaline was
flowing or his time adherence to say my
Julianne was flowing and when he jumped
up on me I just got all super strong and
whatnot no light of the fellow I do want
to get a little sentimental though that
was such a great moment you getting to
present that Oscar to your buddy long
time we would get it and we weren't
together then we were back together and
I mean he shoots off me Capital One
commercials so it's it's great that
we've walked this interesting path
together and got into this place and
when you're on that stage you never
expect that you're gonna present an
award or a deep penultimate award in
this business you know a friend that
you've been around that long because you
know you come from you come from a place
of when that moment happens first the
shock and surprise of it being there and
spike spike in his mohawk mess of it all
you know maybe scream out the house
which is awesome I never do that even
though when they do it to me hood people
go home faster 78
but um know if it was terrifically
heartfelt I was overjoyed for him you
know it made the evening extremely
special and all the Academy Awards I've
been to yeah I was just saying the car
it's probably gonna be like 50 years
from now when mance bags are gone
that'll be the thing when they go to
Academy Awards one of the most amazing
things happening he'll be jumping on my
ass okay so now let's go to the 90s
since this movie set in the 90s when you
go back to that era of Sam Jack you know
you leave that alone
I was working that was good the nanny's
out straight nice well I got cleaning
wood 1990 and then I came to Hollywood
BAM thank you things are real good for
you she's got all right you know I got
here right just the right time yeah that
was only a few of us tell me why you and
Bri are such the odd couple
but such perfection like when we see you
on speed of Michael damn where they been
this whole time when you're working in
certain kinds of environments we were
out in the wilds what we did Kong and
remote locations there's no Wi-Fi
anything so people couldn't get on their
devices you have to talk hangout laugh
together between shots and she and I
seemed like we ended up talking to most
together and hanging out and then we
were leaving I read her script I was
like so you're making a movie and she's
like how do you know because I read it
last night and I know who you want to be
in it and he's never gonna do your
movies and you didn't even ask me
so she good no I was afraid to say no or
I was like are you asking me or not you
asked me so finally it happened Ellis
Arnall ences be banging
see the future Queen in London yeah
that's here Silver Surfer
killing you guys look like you really
this is coordinating melanin magic on
this carpet is giving me the fuchsia
wonder in London did you see a [ __ ]
[Music]
everybody's like you who who the woman
in the pink who's the woman
they don't know serves in the face is
about to find out did you get invited to
Sam 70th birthday party cuz it was like
the party of the century
I could have been here no you couldn't
live she was out of time I heard that it
was a party like no other and Sam I
think there she an event to remember my
goodness ladybug like baby Shawna come
on now go harder go come on baby mean I
felt really bone I was in my hometown
say what to celebrate with my family it
just felt good I'm mad at it I'm not mad
good she's jumping off B and L tonight
I can love something it goes that is
know I can move
[Music]